[Music]
[Applause]
Albert
Breer somehow we make a smooth segue to
Albert Breer the Monday Morning
Quarterback uh Albert thanks for joining
us we've been noodling this around the
first 90 minutes of the show if if I had
a a survey Anonymous survey with members
in the media if they're rooting for
Aaron roders to come back or not how do
you think that survey would play
on I would hope most of us would want to
see him come back just because the story
Line's an awesome one you know I the
idea that somebody can come back this
fast is I mean a v in a vacuum a good
story but on top of that what could that
mean for athletes going forward you know
if they found something here that got a
quarterback back into an NFL game you
know whatever it is like a little over
three months after he tore his Achilles
which I mean whatever 10 15 years ago
was like a death sentence for a football
player that's awesome you know and it's
especially awesome for like the bigger
guys too like you know the bigger guys
are always the ones that have such a
hard time coming back from this um and
so I think on a number of different
levels it'd be a good story if he was
able to do this um and uh yeah I I can't
imagine anybody would not want to
follow um you know Aron Rogers
desperately trying to get the Jets back
in the playoff picture in a weekened AFC
too like the AFC is not what we thought
it was which can be part of this as well
well I think you have an altruistic I
mean you you have the positive spin on
this it feels like there's members of
the media that are either for Rogers or
again yeah that they're for him or
against
him I well I I don't know I mean that's
not our job I I agree I I I understand
that but it feels like people are
picking sides with this or oh Rogers did
you really have a toric killer
all does this come back to like the the
the fact that he's on McAfee every week
and some of the controversial stuff he
says I mean I I don't know I I mean look
like my my dealings with Aaron have been
you know pretty positive over the years
I know you've had some too and um you
know I you know I know that there is
that part of it right like the guy the
guy likes attention and um you know it's
got to be an interesting thing for
Robert Salah to you know get a state of
the union speech every Friday by tuning
into McAfee right like so there's that
part of it where I can understand where
people would be you know a little
annoyed or a little warn out by all of
it um but you know just I mean look like
would you really rather watch Tim Bole
play football than Aaron Rogers you know
what I mean like it's the same as like
would you rather watch Jake Browning
play than Joe burrow would you rather
watch Dorian Thompson Robinson play uh
yeah but those are all different
scenarios that they are they are but
it's like like in the end isn't like
that what it's about well nobody's
rooting for deshun Watson to come back
like people have rooted against DeShaun
Watson or right covered him in a slanted
way I think that that's like a little
that's different though you know what I
mean like regardless of what you think
of what he did if you're convinced that
he did what he's accused of doing then
yeah I absolutely can understand why
somebody might root against him you know
like with Aaron Rogers it feels more
like a they just don't like his
personality you know like I don't know
like it feels like different than deshun
Watson is M Jones done in New
England uh I think it depends on who the
coach is next year um but I think for
this year there's a good chance he is I
think bayy zappy goes out and plays well
on Sunday and runs the offense and is
able to be a distributor out there he
doesn't need to be a world beater but
just gives him a chance and doesn't turn
the ball over um my guess would be that
you know that Matt Jones could be shut
down for the rest of the year and if I'm
the the Patriots by the way like if I'm
not starting him on Sunday I'm not
dressing him because I've seen too many
teams make this mistake where it's like
okay we want to give the kid a reset we
think he's the wirings messed up but
we're goingon to make him the backup so
then the minute like the quarterback the
starting quarterback gets hurt that
whole plan goes up and smoke it happened
with the Jets right like the Jets the
plan was for Zach Wilson to get a real
career reset and be able to sit and
watch and like if the Jets were really
committed to doing that they would have
made him the third Stringer not the
second string ER because the minute the
star gets hurt the second Stringer is
going in right so I think with Mac it's
and the wiring is definitely off like
and he is dealing now with I think some
of the things that Zach Wilson dealt
with where it's a little bit like you
can't get right like that's what the IPS
is right like you just can't get right
um and I think it's for a variety of
different reasons and I think the right
thing for him right now would be to sit
down um whether or not he's done long
term in New England I think depends on
who's coach coing the team and who's
making the decisions in 2024 and we
still don't know who that is okay if
it's Bill
bellich I think Ma would be gone that'
be my guess all right Albert Breer the
Monday Morning Quarterback joining us uh
your take on the last couple of days
with the Carolina
Panthers
um yeah I I think um I think it's an
owner getting a sea legs um you know
I it's interesting because like I had a
question in my mailbag this week um it's
up on the site
that asked me if he's like the next
Snider and I think people ignore like
how often owners stumble around at the
beginning and like it takes a while for
them to figure it out and I think that's
become the default thing like when a an
owner comes in and and and messes things
up in the beginning it's like oh well
he's Dan Snyder well I think what often
happens is these guys come in and
they're so successful in whatever
business they're coming from and they've
always been the smartest guy in the room
and then they come into this environment
and they think okay well I'll just be
able to push all the same buttons I
pushed as a real estate tycoon or as a
hedge fund manager and it's going to
work and football doesn't work that way
you know and so sometimes these guys
have to fall in their face a little and
get bloodied a little and I think that's
what teer is kind of going through right
now and um you know I think that you can
look at the lesson in San Francisco um
where you know Jed York clashed with Jim
Harbaugh and then went through basically
like one-year restarts with um with Jim
tomsa and Chip Kelly and that place was
seen as toxic like one of the worst
organizations in the league and he had
to like basically can control and long
contracts to Kyle Shanahan and John
Lynch and say I trust you guys go fix it
and I think that's sort of where teer is
right now you know is that he's wanted
to be involved but he's not there he's
not in the office every day um he has
sort of Taken ideas from other
organizations and tried to apply them
with people that he's bringing in um as
a result Frank Reich hired a coaching
staff that maybe he wasn't all that
familiar with um they tried to put
together an All-Star team that's always
a tough thing to make work in
football um and you know I I think that
there's just there hasn't been a cogent
like organizational philosophy there but
could you see bich wanting to work for
that owner if he gives him control maybe
yeah but thing this guy feels like he
wants to you know there's a couple you
got Jerry well that's the thing is like
I don't know because like it's you know
what that's it D Dan is like a lot of
these guys like they don't buy the team
to sit on the sideline you know what I
mean like so how do you strike that
balance where it's like you know I think
when that's the other thing is when
these guys first buy these teams they're
gung-ho they want to be involved in
everything well um I mean if David terer
is not there every day but he's
basically operating when he's in the
building as if he's there every day
that's a problem right yeah because you
if you if you're in there like so he
come in on Friday for home games and
leave Tuesday what's the most important
part of the week for a football team
Wednesday Thursday Friday right and
Tuesday for game plan for coaches so
he's missing all of that but he's
operating as if he's the boss and he's
there dayto day um you know like that's
the thing is like how do you strike the
balance between wanting to be involved
and wanting to gather information and
wanting to be a resource and wanting to
use all the business principles that you
have but also like understanding like I
I have to delegate some of this and
there's a lot of stuff that I don't know
and there's stuff that I shouldn't
really involve myself in and there are
some decisions that I need to farm out
to other people um like to me like the
the Assembly of the the All-Star staff
was like a big part of it like he saw
what the Giants did with Brian dbal
right where dbal brought in some guys he
didn't know to coach for him well dball
went through this like huge process
where he had like basically the coaches
who were already on staff group
interview people who were who were
potentially going to come in and work
for them and then he saw what the niners
did right like where the Niners had all
of these guys go through and demo Ryan
and Robert Salah and Mike McDaniel and H
Martin mayew and Rand carthon where they
were getting draft picks for the scouts
and coaches that had come through their
through their um through their through
their system like you know via the
incentive structure the NFL set up for
minority hiring well you know that's
great you know but like is your goal to
hire a good coach or is your goal to get
a Draft pick on the other end of it
right I mean I think that there were all
these ideas that David terer had that
weren't bad ideas but he was just like
applying them all at once and I think as
a result you wound up with this coaching
staff that really didn't had a big
learning curve as far as figuring out
how to work together and then you get in
the season the offense looks like a mess
and the defense doesn't match the
offense and now you're not giving the
the group time to grow together and like
what are you you know so I think that
that's going to be like the big thing
coming out of this is like what is the
Panthers organizational philosophy if
like in a straight line like how would
you describe what they are because up
until this point it feels like they've
been a mishmash of ideas and that's on
the owner for not empowering people to
set what the organizational structure
philosophy culture all that stuff's
going to be Jim harball more attractive
to NFL teams this year or last
year um
I think he would be this year I mean I I
don't know like I I think
like I don't understand why there hasn't
been more interest in him like he hasn't
gotten an offer the last couple of years
you know like and I I don't understand
why like I look like I understand things
didn't end end well in San Francisco
right like but I mean if you look like
so he has built a culture everywhere he
went right he built a culture everywhere
he went when that looks exactly the same
Stanford looks the same as the Niners
looks the same as Michigan right and he
has a certain type of player that is in
every one of those C that was in every
one of those organizations right the the
two the two college teams and the pro
team and like you put the whole thing
together and it's like this guy's Bill
Parcels like he comes in he shakes it up
he knows what he wants to look like it
looks the same everywhere he goes they
have the same philosophy and culture and
the same types of people everywhere he
goes I don't understand why somebody
wouldn't want to buy that buy into that
right like why somebody wouldn't want
that now maybe it's not a 10-year answer
maybe it's a four or five year answer
but I mean look like I I think like if
you look at like Michigan right like he
I mean his team was six and0 without him
on the sideline and that says something
about what he what he put in place there
right and I think like I mean honestly
Saturday freaking hurt for me you know
but like what I saw what I saw
was a staff without its head coach
coaching like it was an NFL game right
like that's that was the difference they
wed the margin they weren't more
talented we'll see that in five years
Ohio state that the Ohio State roster
had way more NFL like way more like
high-end NFL players on it what it was
that they they owned the situations they
owned the margins they won on the
margins they played to win that specific
game and so you know like they they were
great on fourth down they they they were
great on special teams they won the game
with a long field goal Ohio State Miss
long field go Ohio state had short punts
they had long punts um they they they
had the trick plays when they needed
they went for it on fourth down they had
the four-minute drive at the end of the
game and like all of that is part my
point is that all of that is part of
what Jim Harbaugh built and um I I just
I can't understand for the life of me
why you wouldn't why an NFL team
wouldn't look at that and want that um
could he like was he were things hard at
the end in San Francisco yeah they were
like they weren't that was not a great
that was there was not a great
environment in that building
but even when it was really bad what
were they N9 and seven that last
year I think so isn't that right I don't
know I think so maybe I'm the one who's
crazy you know but no Harbaugh's crazy
Harbaugh's crazy but so are a lot of
these
guys yeah crazy successful but you've
dealt with enough of them how many of
them are like like you sort of have to
have a screw loose right nobody's I
don't want normal I mean I that like
he's different that's what you that you
buy into is Bill bich a normal well
adjusted human being uh Albert no I'm
not no I mean it's not like it's it's
just um yeah so I I I
think like to me like I think like he is
I I I felt this way forever like I think
he's Parcels right like he runs hot he
comes in he'll shake up like he'll come
in and he'll shake up whatever place
he's walking into he'll change it in
short order like he may wind up burning
people out and like if you're looking
for a guy to be your coach for the next
15 years probably not it right but like
I don't know like I you
know the way that the way that he's
changed these places and like the
trademark he's put on it like how it
just looks a certain way you know what I
mean it's identifiable there's no
scatter shut oh we're going to try this
or try no it looks like you know what
that looks like um it's pretty
impressive it's pretty impressive and I
say that and it hurts me to say that yes
and you being an Ohio State guy maybe
you're happy to get him out of Michigan
uh great to talk to you as always thank
you thank you Albert all right thanks
Dan Albert Breer Monday Morning
Quarterback